mariupol no se va a rendir a lo que han
asegurado en las últimas horas las
autoridades ucranianas después del
ultimátum lanzado por rusia el alcalde
ya había avisado que la situación en la
ciudad en esta ciudad estratégica del
sur ucraniano es muy complicada y
guerrilla urbana y bombardeos continuos
que han destrozado gran parte de la
ciudad y también preocupa la situación
de los ciudadanos ucranianos de mariupol
que han sido deportados a rusia según ha
denunciado la defensora del pueblo y en
quiebra en quiebra la capital de ucrania
ha habido un ataque contra un centro
comercial que ha dejado ocho muertos a
las sirenas vuelven a sonar en toda la
ciudad están sonando en este mismo
instante y las autoridades nos han dicho
de no salir a la casa y resguardar monos
encontramos como saben en el oeste del
país en la ciudad de libia a poca
distancia de aquí u otra ciudad de la
ciudad de reúne también a las
autoridades de esta ciudad han
denunciado un ataque a un ataque que
habría dañado infraestructura de estado